welcome to the
welcome everybody we are getting closer
to defeating the invisible
scourge as many of you of course know
i mean i guess i'm sort of being serious
in the sense that every day we're one
day closer it's just not really clear
how far we are massachusetts my home
state is starting to do some reopening
i'm going to talk a little bit about
what's going up and at the top of the
hour we are expecting a trump
coronavirus
roundtable on the topic of restaurants
and industry or industry hello
we are standing by on three different
streams three different streams
coming at the top of the hour will be
very exciting
what else do we have i have some clips
to play for you
and we're going to look at the latest
numbers and a whole bunch of different
stuff
we have countries that are doing very
very very poorly russia
india brazil increasingly the most
in trouble places so we're going to be
talking about that
and certainly we are very very far from
over
welcome to everybody watching on twitter
twitch youtube and facebook
much concern over my urban garden uh
it's fine you can check in with me about
that on my instagram page i also have a
watermelon
destruction video on my instagram which
maybe i'll play for people in a little
bit
um yes my hair is completely out of
control i was actually just as a test
i was able to put it in a man bun over
the weekend so it is possible i've
confirmed it's possible
and uh maybe you know if we get to 50
website members i will actually do it on
stream tomorrow
yeah i mean it's actually getting so bad
that a fruit fly flew out of it
yesterday at one point yesterday i went
like this and a fruit fly flew out and
it was really really weird
and scared a lot of people around me
let's see here what else do we have
um okay i guess let's let's get right
into it
um starting with the latest numbers
officially 4.8 million cases globally
318 000 deaths as many of you know
this is a fraction of the real number of
deaths
of the real number of cases rather the
deaths number we believe is relatively
close
in the united states we now have
surpassed 1.5 million cases
and are rapidly approaching 100 000
deaths there are states where things are
improving there are states
where things don't seem to be improving
i talk about that on the broadcast
program and podcast today
new york is one example where we look at
the numbers and they certainly are
getting much better that is the type of
curve that you want to see
we could look at and let's see how
things are going in massachusetts my
home state
um not bad and again it's so we never
had
that big of a peak so we're only down
about half because the peak was not that
high so okay you've got to interpret all
of these numbers
you look at a state like pennsylvania
they were an early hot spot
and then we see okay not not as dramatic
of a decrease but you were still seeing
one so that's all going okay now i i
you all know that i bring you the truth
i have a segment on today's podcast
about the fact that
california and texas one which has been
locked down for two months
and one which has reopened weeks ago the
curves aren't that different
okay so this is the california curve
it's sort of going up this is the texas
curve
where is it
here we go this is the the california
and texas curves are different
in absolute numbers but they are very
similar
in terms of the shape i don't pretend to
know why
are either or both states lying about
data or data i don't know is there
something about
the temperature in texas versus
california it doesn't seem like it
is that i don't know the answer but what
i can tell you is when you look at
new jersey and florida very closed
versus open the curves look similar
when you look at california and texas
one very closed one open the curves look
similar i don't have the answer
i don't know the answer the only thing
i've read about anything remotely like
this
is the idea that the lockdowns
reduce the aggregate number of cases and
deaths
but that the shape of the curve the
increase and the decrease
ends up being very similar i'm not
pretending to know
um anything more than that and hopefully
we will we will learn more about that as
time comes
we are standing by for a top of the hour
trump coronavirus restaurant
event that is coming soon i'm glad that
you are here
um oh people say my voice sounds
strained i know
let me take a sip of water
just kidding i did have the hiccups
earlier
and i think that that may have may have
done a little something to my voice
kevin mccomber says via super chat i'm
for medicare for all but i don't think
most people should go to college they
would be better off working make it
cheaper but definitely not free
mark fillion says uh nothing but sends a
super chat
carmen edward says what's up pacman i'd
like to send to see a good graph on
comparison
how many people died last year this time
to current deaths this year where to
look
yeah so just google excess all-cause
mortality
excess all-cause mortality is what you
want to see
while there is me says did you hear
about the lancet's weekly peer review
general medical journal article
urging american voters to not re-elect
trump i heard about it i didn't read it
yet
and mark filian says hey david love the
show and
everything that you do well if you saw
some of the things i did i don't know
that you would love them but i
appreciate it i appreciate it uh
nonetheless
let's continue looking at our data we
are finally
getting up into the numbers of tests
that are only
a few times short of where we need to be
as opposed to many times short of where
we need to be
we finally had over 400 000 tests
yesterday
we had let's see one two three four five
six
days in a row of 300k plus
that's good so we're starting to get to
a testing number
that is still about 10 it's insane
we now only need to go 10x where we are
as opposed to 50x where we are but okay
we're starting to see a few more tests
um donald trump
just earlier oh oh actually should we do
this now
yeah okay we'll do this now so this is
from last week
donald trump was presented with a space
force
flag in the office and it's pretty
cringe
i'm gonna play it and you'll see a weird
moment where donald trump goes over and
there's like something weird happens to
the flag and everybody flinches it's
really awkward
[Applause]
pay close attention
i don't know what that is that happens
let's get one more look at it
anyway so that went on and then trump
at this same event referred to
supposedly having a super duper missile
that is i think he said 17 times faster
than the ones we have
incredible military equipment
at a level that nobody's ever seen
before we have no choice we have to do
it
with the adversaries we have out there
we have uh
i call it the super duper missile and i
heard the other night 17 times faster
than
what they have right now then you take
the fastest missile we have right now
uh you've heard russia has five times
and china's working on five or six times
we have won 17 times
and it's just gotten the go-ahead
17 times faster if you can believe that
uh general that's something right
17 times faster than what we have right
now so anyway
my understanding is that our fastest
missile is the pj 10 which goes at mach
3. so 17 times faster would be like
mach 51 i don't know i don't know
anything about i mean if we
we tried to get a comment it's not clear
who's saying what it's all really really
weird
um was this you know was this leaking
classified information was
we just have no idea we don't know at
this point in time uh kaylee mcinanny or
mega nanny was asked about it she said
talk to the pentagon the pentagon said
talk to the white house
eventually the pentagon said we're
developing hype we're buying hypersonic
stuff
i have no idea we we just we may never
know the truth of what
trump is talking about here the hang
fouchy
hang fouchy signs have started um
this is hang fouchy hang gates open
up all our states hang fouchy hang gates
you guys get it okay
they they know how to rhyme um and so
that's going on calling for the
death the death before it was fire
fouchy
now it's hang fouchy so that's that's
going on
and then uh oh and then here is the dumb
one
eric trump listen to what he said on
wacky judge jeanine's show
76 days to be exact away and listen
biden loves this biden can't go on stage
without making some
horrible blunder i mean even from his
basement he's making awful gaffes every
single day so
his campaign's thrilled that he's not
going out there and they think they're
taking away donald trump's
greatest tool which is being able to go
into an arena and fill it with 50 000
people
every single time okay i'm not aware of
any arenas where trump had an audience
of 50 000. now let's think that through
one virulent trumpist said dude he went
to
india and he got more than 50 000 people
hold on a second hold on a second
so that was one time and that was a
crowd
for the indian prime minister half the
crowd
left when it was trump's chance to speak
so this
this can't be about that one time trump
went to india someone else wrote me and
said
well look at that crowd when trump went
to the football the college football
game
the crowd was there for the game trump
regularly lying about crowd sizes
apparently it runs in the family
um and let's continue a little bit more
right so they they
will and you watch they'll milk it every
single day between now and november 3rd
and guess what after november 3rd
coronavirus will magically all of a
sudden go away and disappear and
everybody will be able to reopen
they're trying to deprive him of of his
his greatest asset um which is the fact
that the american
people so anyway coronavirus is not
going to go away on election day now
that actually happened with ebola in
2014. i don't know how many of you
remember this but
we had four cases of ebola in the u.s
with two deaths
four cases two deaths you understand
what i'm saying
and up until the day of the 2014
midterms i covered it at the time i was
seven years old at the time
i was doing the show and um the
day after the midterms you never heard
about it again
that was actually what republicans did
with ebola in 2014 we had two deaths
we're close to a hundred thousand here
and this is what eric trump is saying
so he is as much of a liar as don jr but
he's not
as good at telling the lies eric trump i
consider eric trump
the dumb one and i know that that seems
pejorative and
it is but that's the way that i see it
my friends
okay let's get over to twitch i want to
say thank you on twitch to
gmoneyrider who just subscribed and says
five months already i have listened for
more than five years
and the live streams have been some of
my favorite content so far thank you i
appreciate that
also tom has subscribed
on twitch remember you can subscribe for
free with twitch prime if you have an
amazon prime membership
really really easy to do you go to
twitch.amazon.com
welcome if you're watching on youtube of
course remember to
like the stream and to hit that
subscribe
button a few super chats coming in
let's see here mart fillion says
man am i glad to live in canada with our
health care system
i totally understand that matthias
germany says did you see the german
soccer league restarting i did i don't
know much about
what sort of public safety guidelines
they're putting in place
but i did see that they are restarting
no
says deepak gigachad what
is the point of space force i don't know
i i have no idea
bernie sanders says what are your
thoughts on modern monetary theory
numerous interviews about this check out
my interview with stephanie kelton
on the channel from just a couple of
weeks ago was it last week or two weeks
ago
time is weird right now it's in the last
two weeks i interviewed stephanie kelton
i've interviewed pavlina cerneva about
modern monetary
theory and others
so all very very widely documented stuff
on my youtube channel if you're just
joining us we do have a scheduled
trump coronavirus event in just one
minute
none of our feeds were monitoring very
very strongly the washington post
fox news as well as the white house
stream none have yet gone live
so we presume that it's going to be a
little bit longer
uh no ponytail today i did over the
weekend test
and i am able to get a ponytail i do
have pictures of it on my phone
but i am not doing it right now uh also
some fruit flies at one point flew out
of my hair
over the weekend and so it's definitely
getting bad
but here's some interesting news
massachusetts is starting to reopen
so we have a whole bunch of stuff that's
going on in massachusetts but as of
today
massachusetts is in phase one okay
what happens today manufacturing
facilities and construction sites will
open
today with applicable guidelines places
of warship
that's how i call it warship like a
battleship places of warship
will be able to open with guidelines
that require social distancing and
encourage services to be held
outdoors hospitals and community health
centers that attest to safe to specific
public health and safety standards
can begin to provide high priority
preventive care
pediatric care and treatment for
high-risk patients
and then under a staggered approach a
week from today
we will have additional elements open
lab
space will open office space
hello i don't know why everybody can
just work from home i think you should
we'll we'll open limited personal
services including
hair salons boom pet grooming
and car washes so what is my message to
you because of the
prevalence of hair salons may be opening
next saturday next
monday if we are going to get to
the man bun episode of the david pakman
show
we'd better do it this week you
understand what i'm saying my friends
because that could very very
dramatically be different we are off on
memorial day
who knows what my physical appearance
will be like
uh come tuesday may 26th it could be
anything retail will be allowed to
reopen with remote fulfillment and
curbside pickup
also opening on may 25 beaches
parks drive-in movie theaters i don't
know if we have it i mean we must have
some otherwise it wouldn't be on the
list
select athletic fields and courts many
outdoor adventure activities
most fishing hunting and boating outdoor
gardens
zoos reserves and public installations
additional
sectors expected to open on june 1
as part of phase one include office
spaces
in the city of boston with applicable
guidelines so this is what we have here
in massachusetts
each phase will last a minimum of three
weeks and could last longer
um if public health data trends go
negative we may need to go to earlier
phases
there will be industry specific
protocols in advance of future phases
for example
rents restaurant specific protocols will
be drafted in advance of phase
two my belief is that phase two will
contain restaurants
it says very clearly businesses are not
required
to reopen and if you are going to reopen
you must develop a written covid plan
i think it's being handled pretty
responsibly so
i am uh pleased to see that and of
course we're all going to continue
behaving responsibly
ad nauseum as the term may be
okay other super chats coming in
uh let's see here don't want to miss
anybody
jimmy big nuts says is it possible to be
moral and a conservative
anything's theoretically possible give
me an example though that's what i would
like to see
samuel lopez says
i listen to music in english and spanish
english and spanish both
very very strongly robert mifflin says
isn't modern monetary theory counter to
the nordic model
more venezuela uh no those are
those are extremely uh uh
inaccurate oversimplifications mart
fillion says how many lies
in that round table i expect many lies
in today's round table for sure
alex kepcke says david i know we're 39th
in test per capita at the moment but at
a certain point do you think it has to
do with our large population
no per capita accounts for the
population
uh alex i i i if
if you really don't know this then then
okay but this is a teachable moment
i assume that that's a joke per capita
is adjusted to the population okay i
don't know
at this point i am at a loss as to how
else i can explain that
danny thompson says how did i miss that
we needed space force
for protecting american interests in
space there was a lot of
war language in that video super surreal
very much so
tiffany nicole says i love you david
love you too very much appreciate the
support thank you
uh okay i had a couple of other things
to
look at let me see here
um okay oh i am gonna do new members
soon we do have a goal of 25
i will put my hair in a man bun at 50.
remember if you're just joining us to
like the stream
on youtube and to follow if you're
watching on twitch
i want to say thank you to oceanova
who has subscribed can you believe it
for 10 months
on twitch and says i attempted a trim of
my hair
and ended up with a buzz cut have you
rocked that look before
i used to have like a kind of kid and
play high and tight back
in sixth and seventh grade it wasn't
great
it really wasn't great so i've stepped
away from that
to quite a degree if you're just joining
me
and you're looking for something with
some levity here's a video i posted
yesterday to my
instagram page remember that i'm david
pakman on
instagram i absolutely
destroyed a watermelon look at me take
this thing down it stood no chance
against me take a look at this
going right in with the lefty use of a
knife
and just absolutely obliterating this
thing one layer at a time
and it really it it offered no
resistance it completely fell apart
and i was able to get to that delicious
sweet sweet red fruit
and obviously had to chill it and just
look at this this is the type of high
quality content you get on my instagram
at david.pakman
it it just had no shot guys the
watermelon was never going to make it
out of this alive
and just getting rid of that pith as i
like to call it
and then we go right in look at this
look at that slicing action
absolutely stunning filling up
containers
boom one container done second one here
we go
filled absolutely right up then i have
to pull in mason jars because there was
so much watermelon
unleashed big mason jar boom boom boom
small mason jar
and then i start just eating a few
pieces of it isn't that stunning
has anybody ever seen anything like that
and that is a time lapse
that was a 16x time lapse and
it was a minute long so i guess that
means it took me 16 minutes to fully
break it down
and uh that is that's on my instagram
page make sure
you're following me there at
david.pacman because it is
very very important uh to know how to
break down
how to break down a watermelon okay
other things i wanted to play for you
guys today i do have donald trump's
twitter up
and he's been been tweeting a lot of
adjet trash he
just tweeted a video calling mitt romney
a loser
mitt romney is one of the few republican
senators who's actually
currently an elected official and
calling trump out and so now trump has
this pinned to his twitter page
yeah barack obama will be re-elected
president of the united states plan b
plan c
plan d now gone and so you start looking
at the romney math and you're saying
well then what's plan e
tears in a gloomy atmosphere as
supporters left the convention center in
boston following romney's concession
speech
that was a race i have to say folks that
should have been won
i wouldn't call anything encouraging for
hillary clinton at the moment to be
honest with you my friend hillary
clinton has called donald trump to
concede the race
president of the united states anyway so
this is a video with just
loser that's what donald trump tweeted
there trump tweeting oil
energy is back trump tweeting sleepy joe
is wrong again this is the president
right
look at this absolutely unhinged tweet
right here
so the so-called hhs whistleblower was
against
all caps chloroquine as trump says it
then why did he make and sign an
emergency use authorization
nora o'donnell said he shared his
concerns with a reporter in other words
he leaked a dumb 60 minutes hit job on a
grandstanding
never trumper these are the rantings of
an
absolute madman um
and then just you know just trash trash
this is the president of the united
states how many tweets is this all day
dozens absolutely dozens tweeting oh da
i can't dan bongino has me blocked
yeah so i can't see what the dan bongino
retweet is
uh james woods tweeting retweeting
compliments from conservative actor
james woods
uh tweeting conspiracy videos about
cnn's caitlyn collins because she took
her mask off at the end of the press
briefing
it's crazy it's the i cannot believe
that this is the reality we are in and
we need to make sure that
it is removed in november we need a new
reality starting on january
21st thanks to frisky seal for
subscribing with three months with
twitch prime i very much appreciate that
also want to say thank you to stephen
how do i pronounce this rathji steven
rathshee
is um new member number one today
at joinedpakman.com and i also want to
say thanks to eli gray
who is new member number two today at
joinpackman.com very much appreciate
that
uh charlie says very wet from the
standpoint of watermelon
absolutely jacob ratner says what are
your thoughts on bernie or busters who
don't seem to understand harm reduction
that honestly it's i don't know i it's
uh it's their problem
um i don't you know i can't it can't be
on me to explain everything to everybody
i've
issued my perspective and i'm not going
to go around arguing with people or
evangelizing
but listen to some of them biden over
trump is not harm reduction
okay just own it just say you preferred
trump and then we're all on the same
page right let's just just get it out of
the way
mark fillion says david how far are we
from a cooking show
we are pretty far we are pretty far from
a cooking show for now
jr says media hating fringe praise
hungry adderall snorting racist
data distorting crude lying
entertainment
soon turns to anger anger to exhaustion
exhaustion to apathy if not
checked stay awake stay smart
all right a very important message from
jr
daniel rivera says what safeguards are
or will there be to prevent another
trump
there are none there are none and
we may well have another trump or we may
have this trump for another four years
jerry lou rice says you said my last
name right
it's rathji rathshee okay very good
mike shashefsky says if somehow
everything went back to normal in an
instant what public style
establishment would you visit first i
have no idea
i have no id i'd have to think about
that but none none obviously
strikes me as the one um but i would i
would have in any number of places to
visit and i would
get right to them for sure if you're
just joining us we are about
10 11 minutes past when we were
expecting a
coronavirus reopening round table
with the president and restaurant
executives and industry or
industry leaders as trump says scheduled
for 2 pm eastern
has not yet started and we are not live
anywhere yet usually fox news will take
it live
in advance of the start of the event we
aren't there yet
we aren't there yet so we will continue
to stand by
name withheld asks does trump know
putting oil in reserve was a bad
thing and conceding to saudi arabia and
artificially trying to keep oil prices
from plummeting
trump has no idea what he's doing your
question
implies that trump has any kind of
understanding
of economics currency energy
uh geopolitic i mean just trump has no
understanding of any of these things so
no donald trump does not know uh
about any of that stuff at all at all
i see our friends on twitch some new
twitch
followers are having trouble signing up
with prime
and i don't know why this happens but um
it's very easy if you're watching on a
computer
if you put your mouse over the video
like over my face
a blue button will show up which will
allow you to subscribe with prime
you do have to connect amazon prime to
twitch prime it's very easy you can read
about it at twitch.amazon.com
but i don't know uh there there often is
confusion
about how to sign up with twitch prime
and
it's it's relatively straightforward
relatively straightforward
and frisky seal for example just
signed up with twitch prime which we
love
which we absolutely love okay
mark fillion says when are you getting
on with a chess tournament
we may do it later this week we've just
been so busy
between the regular show and
you know podcast all that stuff we've
expanded the broadcast show 10 minutes
uh every single day 10 it's 10 longer
every single day
and then we've got the streams we've had
a lot of uh
you know elements of accounting and
legal lately just getting
certain certain things sorted out so
uh i would like to do it later this week
i will announce it if that's happening
if not
it might be it might be a little bit
later it might be a little bit later
but we will announce it for sure in the
meantime i've not even had that much
time to play chess uh
personally um oh oh people are wanting
the youtube
yeah let me show so we did my um
we did my watermelon video on youtube
with a very specific soundtrack i'll
show it to you and see what people think
about this
i think it's pretty funny uh hold on a
second
here we go so we did the watermelon
video on my instagram david.pacman with
absolutely no audio
but check out how we did it on youtube
and people seem to be reacting to this
beautifully people seem to really eat
this right up
we just got an ad here here we go
supposing we hit the body
with a tremendous whether it's
ultraviolet or just
very powerful light and i think you said
that hasn't been checked but you're
going to test it and then i said
supposing you brought the light inside
the body
like a moment you can do either through
the skin or uh
in some other way through the skin and i
think you said you're going to test that
too
sounds interesting right and then i see
the disinfectant
where it knocks it out in a minute
and is there a way we can do something
like that
by injection inside or
or almost a cleaning because you see it
gets in the lungs and it
does a tremendous number so it'd be
interesting to check that so that you're
going to have to use
medical doctors with but it sounds
interesting to me
the new headline is trump asks people to
go outside that's dangerous
here we go same old group uh are you
ready
i hope people enjoy the sun there we go
so timed perfectly timed absolutely
perfectly
that could be a good tick tock thing
right now can you do can you does
anybody know can you do a minute long
video on tick tock i don't even know
i just have such a lack of familiarity
with tick tock
anybody know how long is a tick tock
video
we don't know you can do a minute
okay i i may upload that to my tech talk
beautiful
nobody knows all right very good i love
it when nobody in the chat has any idea
okay let me say a few other thank yous
el
mari vasimis says hi would like to know
if you get a lot of ladies what do you
think i'll marry come on
aj brown has subscribed at the soy boy
level
robin says hi david i live in south
africa why does president trump never
mention countries from
africa when comparing the u.s testing
stats
i don't know that trump is aware of many
countries from africa
uh and i know that that sounds crazy but
didn't he once made up
the name of an african country that
didn't exist i think he combined
zambia and namibia with to create nambia
at one point so i would certainly not
expect
much of that from donald trump
whatsoever
he uh is trump is barely aware of africa
it's tragic tragic but he barely is
let's see if donald trump has
uh updated the start time of this event
not so far just the mitt romney thing
so yeah we don't know exactly when this
is going to be starting but we are
standing by
standing by and it could be starting
very very soon let me say thank you to
fresh tank for subscribing with twitch
prime
twitch prime subscription i absolutely
love it
and donald trump uh was scheduled to
speak
18 minutes ago 18 minutes ago
it has not yet it has not yet started
welcome if you're watching on twitter
twitch facebook or youtube it looks like
this has been
again rescheduled for two minutes from
now we do have a sort of countdown going
the washington post has gone live with a
black screen they're blacked out or
browned out as some people like to say
the white house feed has not started but
we again have a 90-second countdown
on the fox news channel a mark fillion
says cannot
wait to play against you oh yeah playing
against me in chess is really no big
deal i mean i'm not
i'm not that good quite frank in fact
i'm pretty bad
uh i was only beating in my in my last
chest
tournament i was really only beating
people who don't play at all like people
who were absolutely
clueless at chess and um
you know there was really nothing
special to it i must say
let me invite you to oh we've got a
weird zoom there we go
let me invite you to support
the stream and all of our content by
grabbing a membership on my website at
joinpacman.com we have quadrupled
the computing power the resources
on our website because sometimes the
website would crash
during streams we are primarily funded
by memberships on our website so
we had a very rough march in april very
very rough
722 members canceled in march and april
why
because twenty percent of the country's
unemployed i get it
i get it with i harbor no hard feelings
or resentment whatsoever
if you are someone who can support the
work we do
with a dollar a month two dollars a
month right i mean there's no
there's no very low barrier to entry do
it during a stream
at joinpakman.com i will thank everybody
we have two people who already signed up
our goal is 25 if we get to 50
tomorrow i will do the stream with a man
bun i may be getting a haircut next week
so
you know we're getting we have limited
time to make that a reality
and if you want to save 66 off of your
membership
the coupon code is 2020 now and i know
we joke around about this stuff
but um it really it really has been
inspiring to see
uh people who have stepped up and signed
up
722 members is a lot for us to lose in a
relatively short period of time
and several hundred folks have signed up
to make up for it
and we appreciate everybody and i you
know we joke about who it's
there's a lot of jokes i don't care if
you use a coupon code or not i don't
care if you pledge on
patreon instead it all helps it all goes
to the same place we've not done any
hour reductions
or layoffs everybody is
working at the same levels as they were
before the pandemic and my goal my goal
is to keep it that way for a very very
long time my friends so the best way to
make that a reality
is with those website memberships chris
v
says if trump wants to reopen everything
will he also hold his huge rallies again
absolutely trump is desperate
to hold those rallies and there is no
doubt
no doubt that he is uh going to be
doing that for sure um okay
let's see what else we have going on
here
um a few other people i want to thank
over on twitch
be prides and fat clemenza
as well as chimpy butts love it
have all signed up with twitch prime
which is uh
very very exciting back over on youtube
dark knight says man bun all the way
yeah i don't know what the d i mean it
was kind of oh no this thing popped up
behind me again
that is just the word that thing keeps
popping up it's an update to an
app i'm gonna have to clear that again
momentarily um
some by the way that that means somebody
somebody hacked in
and bad bad things are happening no i'm
kidding it's just there's the same app
the pdf related app that wants to update
let me take care of that real quick i
don't want to show everybody my back so
i'm just going to brown out for a second
all right there it is imagine if a
picture of me popped up on the screen
behind me that would be incredibly
embarrassing
okay back we are my friends back we are
yeah anyway so i don't know why people
care about a man bun so much
but i um i could do it now and i'm
getting a haircut
probably in about 10 days so we we have
a limited limited opportunity
during which that uh may become a
reality
and then it's gonna be it i'm gonna be
shaving haircut
it's over my friends it's over i'm not
keeping this going for too too much
longer
we are still standing by for donald
trump trump in a propaganda
reopening coronavirus restaurant
executive
event of some kind uh trump will just
tell a bunch of lies during it but then
there
i am told that there will be questions
from the media
and that is really mostly mostly what we
are
uh what we are here for um
okay what else did i have to do
here i had a couple of other videos that
i wanted to show people let me see if i
can pull
let me think of the right way to pull
them up i think probably
going to aaron rupar's twitter
a couple other videos i wanted to go
over before things get started
not the bar clips let me see where they
were
oh my god by the way what is this let me
take a look at what this is
shady's bar owner in albany tells large
crowd he can't open as he planned at
noon
lawyers advised him not to contest the
attorney general's demands
the attorney general
they brought it to the court they are
they granted they granted them uh
i don't know this last stuff they
granted them this in order to
close us down or 30 has advised us oh my
god
okay so a whole crowd without masks
desperate i guess to go to shady's bar
at noon today
they're not getting in um
where were these latest videos here
oh actually this was it so check this
out um
here is karl rove attacking obama
for his commencement speech over the
weekend like they have
nothing they can't defend trump so now
they're attacking obama for
virtual commencement check this out it
is so unseemly for a former president to
take
the the virtual commencement ceremony
for a series of uh
historically black colleges and
universities and turn it into a
political drive-by shooting
i mean i i i you know this is a moment
where these young graduates could be
inspired for to a life of service to
you know recognize that life is going to
bring challenges and how we handle the
challenges is going to
is going to demonstrate our character
there are lots of positive messages that
the former president
could have delivered but the news that
we have out of this speech out of this
appearance is
he says quote the pandemic has finally
fully
torn back the curtain that so many of
the folks in charge know what they're
doing
don't know what they're doing that is
completely accurate and the funny thing
is
karl rove is acting like the only thing
that went on during that virtual
commencement speech over the weekend
was that obama attacked trump that was
one line
most of the speech was exactly what he's
describing it was a message of
inspiration from barack obama
that things are difficult that we will
get past
this that learning to deal with
difficulty isn't
like the speech was exactly what karl
rove says
it could have been and it also said
that we have now realized the lack of
capacity
that the current administration has for
dealing with problem it was what karl
rove wanted
and yet he still has to go around and
pretend like it was something else it's
these people have absolutely no shame
they're they're truly embarrassing
absolutely embarrassing
uh okay let's see here
jr says while we're waiting do you think
you will be selling coffee again anytime
soon am i wrong did you sell it to begin
with
we did so here's the reality we were
only selling about 50 bags of coffee a
month
it just wasn't enough to justify the
logistics of it it we you know we needed
to get labels
we needed to get we had to print our
coffee labels and have them sent to the
coffee roaster
we had to then you know manage customer
service
for the shipping component of it the
coffee roaster would then invoice me
monthly
we were selling 50 bags a month it just
it wasn't worth it
so we closed the program about a year
ago and i don't imagine that we are
going to go back to the coffee program
danny thompson says albany minnesota not
new york oh sorry sorry albany minnesota
that
start from the accents i started
wondering if it was new york
alan n says talk about hitler's
achievements be unbiased
what an idiotic super chat i hope that
was worth two bucks
townsend coke says does your voice actor
get a kick out of hatred mail yes he
does
and actually patriot male guy's
wife loves hatred mail from what i'm
told she doesn't much care about all of
his other professional voice over work
but hatred mail she really loves which
is just
hilarious let me say thank you to joshua
gwyn
joshua gwynne has done something
unbelievable
which is joshua grabbed a membership on
my website
joinedpakman.com and has gotten us to
three new website members today
i invite you to consider getting a
membership yourself
at joinpacman.com when you sign up
this blue box
for lack of a better term starts filling
up
and you alone can get this thing to fill
up and overflow and explode
off of the side of the screen we're at
three of 25
and of course the coupon code 2020 now
is widely available anybody can use it
and it makes a membership just
two bucks a month which is a pretty damn
good deal i must say
anthony sanchez says sell toilet paper
you know we're not really looking the
problem
for us we sell a bunch of different gear
on our website and on youtube
it's a lot of logistics for very low
profit margins like focusing on
memberships which are far more scalable
makes a lot more sense you know we sell
especially now with coronavirus
uh delaying shipping times for so many
things
selling physical goods is just a
nightmare it really is i don't know that
it's our what i would call our core
competency to use a little bit of uh
business school related vocabulary
thanks to chris r for the super chat
skillet queso says was that drive-by
shooting comment a dog whistle
uh i've no idea what you're talking
about i'm sorry ben taylor says hey
david
been taking a break here it has been
nice to get away
but nice to see you and your amazing
blue eyes oh my god
by the way i had an ex who called me
gordita cute that your mom
calls you davisto holy [ __ ] i half the
time when ben sends super chats i don't
know what he's talking about but
ben's a big supporter and he's been
around for a while and i very very much
appreciate ben's support
even when i don't know exactly what he's
saying zachary
oh did you mean karl rove used the term
drive-by shooting is that i'm now
realizing
karl rove said that drive and was that
right it was probably a dog whistle yes
that was probably a dog whistle by by my
best assessment
uh okay zachary foster says deena
grayson
deleted covidius tweet about germany she
made two weeks ago
germany announced his lowest positive
rate since beginning of virus i didn't
see that tweet
and i've not interviewed dina grayson i
do follow her
on twitter but i did not see that tweet
let me say thank you to lynn wellings
lin is new member number four today at
joinedpakman.com
and brad priddle is new member number
five
today at joinpacman.com the goal is 25
and if we get to 50 i will stream
tomorrow with a man bun
it may be one of the last opportunities
for it
as uh it looks like in massachusetts we
are getting
very very close to haircuts
being available so limited opportunities
remain
let me say some thank yous over on
twitch to some really great people
christy mack has gifted a subscription
stacanov has subscribed and says trump
is watching tv again
and can't be bothered to work
adrian liebe has subscribed with pop
prime
tai schneids has subscribed
with prime very very exciting i i do
appreciate that
other super chats are coming in aj brown
seconds the toilet paper selling idea
we're not selling toilet paper guys i'm
sorry
sabrina zafar's has thoughts on baker's
reopening phases for massachusetts do
you feel it's a bit early will you be
getting a haircut next week
i don't know if i'm getting a haircut
next week i do have the guidelines here
i don't think it's too quick because
right now
almost nothing is changing so in the
immediate
what's going on is manufacturing
facilities and construction sites get to
open with
applicable guidelines people not close
together mandatory masks
places of worship concerns me because i
worry they won't follow the guidelines
even though it says here you need
social distancing and you've got to be
ideally you'll hold services outdoors
i think that it is good to start
preventative care the number of people
in the hospital with coronavirus in the
state is only a couple thousand
in a state of six and a half million and
the
the the long-term effects of people
skipping preventative care
and starting to be diagnosed for
conditions is problematic so i think
that that's good
um and then next week you know some of
these other things are going to open
the numbers in massachusetts are pretty
good we've had under three percent case
growth rate every day for about two
weeks
we've been under two percent case growth
rate for most of the last week
we even had under one percent case
growth rate i don't think it's too early
and you know the other thing sabrina i
know a lot of people are going to go
absolutely crazy on me for saying this
but i have a story coming up today about
how
states that have opened some of the
states that have opened
have the exact same trajectory as states
that have been closed for two weeks and
i'm talking about
places that um states that have been
closed for two months there are states
that have been open two to three weeks
and the curve is almost identical to
states that have been in lockdown now is
it because the lockdown states
people are ignoring the guidelines that
could be is it for some i don't pretend
to know the answer
but it seems on balance these are pretty
okay
guidelines for the state of uh of
massachusetts right now
alfredo gonzalez says my comments are
insta-deleted on your last video don't
you think that if
blacks commit more violent crime they
also have more police interactions
dude i don't know what you're talking
about we're not deleting we don't have
time to go we get 3000 youtube
actually three to six thousand youtube
comments a day
we have a staff of four okay we don't
have the time to go and individually
delete comments if your comments are
being deleted
uh it's because other people are
flagging them as spam
and i don't even look at you youtube
comments we don't we don't manage that
at the show so i don't even know what
you're talking about
donna williams says thanks for doing
these my pleasure
sean m says didn't trump give a hyper
political speech at the boy
scouts a few years ago yes you did
chris r says any thoughts about camping
and national parks reopening
you know it mostly seems okay the
concern would be
that a lot of those places have shared
bathroom facilities
and that's where i would be concerned
people just out in the wilderness don't
concern me the contagion in
out in public in outdoors is so
low but i do have a concern about the
shared facilities
absolutely let me say thank you to kevin
parnell
kevin is new member number six today and
haiko albrecht is new member number
seven
today at joinpakman.com thank you
so much uh for everybody that's been
signing up at joinpacman.com as i've
mentioned before
we got destroyed in the membership from
the standpoint of membership
we lost 722 elements of membership
during march and april that means people
who canceled
because of what's going on so we we like
extra extra appreciate everybody who's
been signing up lately
which is why i want to extra thank heiko
albrecht and kevin purnell
as well as brad priddle lynn wellings
joshua gwynne eli gray
and stephen rathji all of whom are
today's
seven new members of the day you can
join them trust me you can do it
at joinpacman.com
madeline welsh sends a super chat ben
taylor says i heard you say your mom
calls you dawutito and thought it was
cute because i had an
ex from colombia that called me gordita
you're a guy right ben gordita
you know what i'm not even getting
involved i don't i don't know
that it's a beautiful story thank you
alex
kepcke says if you could go to dinner
with your favorite president ever
where would you and trump go i guess i
would go to a kfc
or the place with the taco bowls inside
trump tower that seems to be donald
trump's
favorite food at this point in time i
don't know
okay i want to say thanks to get trump
out 2020
for gifting a community subscription on
twitch
also thank you to emptachion
for the support on twitch as well thank
you very very much
also um okay people already asked about
the chess tournament i'm not
ready to announce the next one yet but i
i may have an announcement later this
week
also thanks to chimpybutts for gifting a
subscription on twitch
leica says via super chat hi david can
you consider doing a piece on how trump
and republicans use
darvo as a gaslighting tactic
i've never heard that before is that an
acronym
darvo stands for oh deny attack
reverse victim and offender yes that i
i call that gaslighting actually i don't
even know that you need as complex of an
acronym
i just call it gas lighting waffles
giraffes says just stopping by
for elements of standpoints absolutely
absolutely very very important um i see
people once again
asking about my watermelon video oh you
know what
let me let me address something actually
let's see if i can
just easily pull this back up so
on my instagram david.pakman i posted a
time lapse video yesterday of me
slicing a watermelon
no matter what i post it's actually one
of the funniest things
is seeing how people complain about
everything so the complaints i got
during this included david number one
that's not the right way to do it you
should cut the entire
watermelon in half and then break down
the subsequent pieces so that this was
the wrong way to cut it number two
david that was the wrong type of knife
you should be using a chef's knife or a
cleaver
in order to break that down number three
david your knife technique
is inappropriate you are holding the
knife in the wrong way
number four david did you throw the rind
away
you shouldn't do that it's wasteful you
should keep the rind
and pickle it and it makes a fantastic
snack david
number five couldn't you have better
planned ahead for the number of
containers
that you needed uh it was obvious from
the size of the watermelon that you
weren't going to fit the entire
watermelon in those two containers
you could have planned for something
better all along like
don't people understand like i know that
this is a silly way to cut a watermelon
i i understand that
i'm doing it as a goof it's a video this
is the internet so
you know sir this is twitter is what i
felt like saying
um but no matter what you post
somebody is disgusted with what it is
that you were doing there's always a
criticism and i think that's why they
call it the internet
that's that's that's what it is but i
was extremely pleased
with the taste of this watermelon
despite being an early season watermelon
it was
absolutely tasty no regrets
no regrets whatsoever i appreciate it
okay let's see here um
candido moreno says viva la raza okay
name withheld says hey david can you ask
joe rogan what percent of the 90 000
dead was preventable if trump would have
acted sooner
i don't know why joe rogan would know
that he's not like an epidemiologist
right
i mean it's like i could ask him but i
don't know why it matters what he thinks
on that
chris says trumpists love when he calls
people out and his anti-political
correctness
but when obama criticizes him they care
about proper presidential behavior
suddenly oh it's totally uh it's a it's
an incredible double standard for sure
cameron jones says can we stay take a
step back
and talk about the blacks yeah can you
imagine interjecting in a stream and
saying
david you're not talking enough about
the bad things that you could be saying
about black people like what is what is
wrong with people
honestly nasty questions says when you
go live my bff and i text each other
deepak
alert thanks for your elements of
analysis i think your knife technique is
on point by the way
you know the one thing that could have
been said is i think that there are
points during this video where
i actually no i'm not even doing it
you're not supposed to put your index
finger
on top of the blade but i don't think
i'm actually doing that in this video
yeah i think my and for the most part
i'm also cutting away there is one point
where i cut towards me which is a little
dangerous let me see where it was
right uh hold on it's coming up right
there
i did that little slice towards me and i
think that's that's the fair criticism
that probably was not
the exact safest way to do that
but i think overall i exhibited pretty
uh this was a joke by the way when i
three times went up like i was gonna
smash the thing i think that i exhibited
pretty safe uh
pretty safe knife technique there
nothing nothing to worry about nothing
to write home about certainly but
not a big deal okay let me say thank you
to lee ventura lee ventura is new member
number eight today at joinedpakman.com
beth lewis hey beth beth is new member
number nine
today kim matthew
is new member number 10 today very much
appreciate that
and you can get your name announced
by grabbing a membership at 2020
now thank you very exciting
uh eileen aardward
says rolling on the floor laughing all
right
mark fillion says i just wanted to
clarify the comment i made a couple of
days ago
okay mark i have no recollection of that
uh
of course this is a grim situation but i
feel that focusing on the people that
recovered would allow for a silver
lighting
all right fair theo love says turn
on tune in drop
out right tiffany nicole says the fact
that you're left-handed excuses it all
oh yeah that's another thing i was using
a right-handed knife
here with my left hand because i'm
useless with my right hand
so that's another thing to consider it
was a right-handed knife
and i was doing the best i could to
account for that uh
and using it using it lefty and i think
that that's important to
to consider by the way that's a joke
that's a joke
okay tiffany nicole says oh wait no
i just read that all ep it's the
destination that counts not the journey
as far as the watermelon is concerned i
agree
townsend [ __ ] says it's [ __ ] not coke
lol all right townsend [ __ ]
very good i i apologize for
mispronouncing your way
in a not vulgar way my apology
karen paul angelo is new member number
11 today at joinedpakman.com
thank you karen i so appreciate that
very very much really appreciate your
support
if you are just joining us we are
45 minutes past the scheduled start
of today's propaganda round table
with restaurant executives and industry
leaders we don't yet know when
this is actually going to start if we
look at trump's twitter
we still have no tweet updating us about
the start time so we'll just hang and
chat with people
i want to say thanks to half vamp for
subscribing with twitch prime
spooby has subscribed for three months
at tier one which i very much appreciate
a jr says like with trump like
trump why shouldn't you go into business
with a watermelon
their cd okay that that's a dad joke
janelle's staff says david why does it
seem like trump is so obsessed with
obama it's getting kind of creepy
oh yeah trump realizes
that obama is ten times the man trump
could ever be
and it makes him extraordinarily
insecure
and that's why he's gone out of his way
to either undo as much of obama's
work as he can and the stuff he can't
undo or the stuff that he likes
he takes credit for uh like the
uh what was it called is it the uh
heroes
act or the veteran veterans choice
veterans choice veterans choice
was something obama did trump did like
some minor extension and he takes credit
for it
it's whacked it's absolutely and totally
whacked
okay justin d says how will trump is
defend the new saudi debacle
do you do you mean the oil or what maybe
i haven't
heard of whatever it is you're referring
to yet i need a little elaboration there
adam bennett says watching from the uk
thanks for a great commentary
greetings to everybody in the uk i was
in london and oxford
just a few months ago feels like years
ago at this point in time given
everything
that's gone down but i was just recently
there and
love it love it london is just a
tremendous city
tremendous city and hope to get back
there
soon who knows when it'll be safe let me
say thank you to
rap cities on graz who has subscribed
for seven months with twitch prime
and says david have you ever tried to
get george lakoff on the show
to talk about how trump is using wartime
language to talk about the pandemic
and the implications that has george
lakoff has been on my program
once or maybe even twice it's been a
little while
and we have not had him on recently but
it's a good idea
i like that idea and we should
absolutely see whether we can uh
whether we can make that a reality it
would be absolutely great to do that
okay um if you were just joining us let
me refresh
our coronavirus numbers we are
at 4.8 million confirmed cases globally
and 318 000 deaths
three of the biggest if we look at
yesterday
by new cases russia
brazil and india as i've been saying for
about 10 days now
are rapidly becoming the epicenters when
you look at their
curves it is very very ugly here's
russia
not good here is their death toll not
good
uh here is brazil notice something in
common between brazil
and russia and the united states brazil
not a good curve
sunday's very often there is less
reporting so we will we will see
what the deal is with that the death
numbers spiking in brazil as well
and then india now at 100 000 cases
still a fraction of where we are
that is not the type of curve that you
want to see
and then also when it comes to deaths
things not looking good
in india uh so you know for about 10
days
i've been looking at the percentage case
growth in russia brazil and
india and and today shockingly
we don't have all the numbers yet but
russia has almost as many new cases as
we do today we'll see what it looks like
by the end of the day
but that is uh russia is having a real
problem india's having a real problem
same with brazil how is uk i think uk is
actually doing all right
yeah okay so you know they've plateaued
and we're seeing a slow decline
slow decline the death numbers declining
far more rapidly in the uk and that's
good to be seeing
as well uh oh let's see is this live
that's been tremendously impacted by
what's happening with covet
and uh it's an industry that we're
working very hard with and
on we're looking at doing deductibility
so that a corporation can use a
restaurant
entertainment clubs etc and get
deductibility i think that'll really
have a big impact steve can maybe talk
about it steve mnuchin it's happening
but i'd like to have some of these
leaders talk about real quickly about
their
company and the industry and any ideas
they have and i think we can do it in
front of the media
for a little while and then we can
answer a couple of questions and we're
going to get back to business okay
please well mr president mr vice
president
secretary mnuchin secretary scalia and
everyone else here including my
my brethren from the uh the restaurant
industry thanks so much for
for having us here it's an honor uh for
me to to be here representing
uh 10 000 restaurants in in the u.s we
have burger king
popeyes and tim hortons uh these
restaurants are owned
by small businesses uh we have it's
funny when i think of restaurants those
aren't the places i think of those seem
more like kind of
food factory type places the restaurants
day in and day out we have
we've been in the restaurants working
as an essential service since the
beginning of the crisis in in march
we have had our drive-throughs open and
delivery open but we've still had a
tremendous
impact on our business and so we're
really looking forward to the process of
reopening the economy we're opening the
country
we already have about a thousand
locations
around the country that have started to
open the dining rooms with reduced
uh capacity we've added ppe we've added
safe
and social distancing in the restaurants
to ensure that people can come in
we have acrylic screens in the front
counter we have masks and gloves for the
employees to ensure that
everyone feels safe our guests and our
team members
and i just wanted to to thank the
president
mr president and your administration i
think you've acted i'm curious what you
guys think i mean i haven't been to any
of these places in 20 years i think the
last time i went to a burger king i was
15.
but it doesn't seem like now is the time
where i would start going back to them
businesses and i think there's a lot we
think that can do
also by the way calling burger kings
like area with tables a dining room
i just also find really funny adding
here is the this idea of extending
uh the eight-week deadline uh we think
that uh eight-week deadline
when it when it was implemented uh was
uh probably you know eight weeks
probably seemed like an eternity but
today we're
we're in the the tenth week of the of
the pandemic and i think it's going to
take
some time for our restaurants and our
owners to get back
uh to the capacity levels and the
traffic levels that we were seeing
pre-covered
and so a little more time we think
probably
taking it to 24 weeks uh would be
appropriate to allow even this guy says
more restaurant
owners that are participating in the
program to be able to uh
to to manage through and re-hire the
employees which is what the the purpose
of ppp was intended for
uh there was two other things that i
think are important uh for us
one is um we think uh business liability
protection for small businesses
is important um you know that we're
going to see
potentially with the reopening of the
economy with the reopening of small
restaurants we're going to see frivolous
i think and unfounded lawsuits against
restaurant owners against small
businesses
that are trying to do the right thing
trying to survive and trying to
keep their their businesses going so we
um we firmly believe that protection
uh from these types of frivolous
lawsuits would be uh helpful
it's really burger king that wants that
protection i don't know that the local
mom and pop is actually a huge risk of
that and that's actually scary that
they're going to use this to just give
blanket lawsuit protection to huge
corporations like burger king
of the ppp and we think there should be
additional funds available for us to be
able to weather
and continue to weather the storm but
we're really proud to be here proud to
be part of
this extraordinary group of restaurant
leaders and thank you so much for the
opportunity to be here
well thank you there's a lot 10 000
restaurants and
some big that's some big group and good
group too i know
i know you changed and i know a lot
about your company it's a great company
so
uh you'll be back very soon i have no
doubt about it and some of the things
you mentioned we'll be talking about i
do want to say before we go further
so this was a very big day
therapeutically
cure wise and vaccine wise uh tremendous
progress has been made
as i've been saying for two weeks
because i've been seeing what's going on
and today
i think spearheading it largely and this
was a very very uh
some big announcements are are coming
and have just come out
and the market's up almost a thousand
points you'll check your market you're
i'm sure you did before you walked in
the room but i i imagine your company's
doing better today than it was
a week ago right we're focused on the
profitability of our franchisees that's
my focus
okay good so what we have is uh
big announcements coming big
announcements have already come
and tremendous progress has been made
therapeutically cure-wise and also
obviously vaccine to meet there are
therapeutically and cure is more
important than vaccine
because it's immediate and if we have
something
even people that are very sick right now
we try and expedite everything so it
goes
really quickly really really quickly
like
let's get it going immediately so
if you have somebody that's not going to
make it if you have somebody that's
going to pass away going to die
and if we have something that we think
works we want to get them
immediately into those hospitals or
wherever the people are located so
that's being talked about also with the
fda with dr
stephen hahn who's doing a fantastic job
and so we're trying to expedite things
but very importantly just overall uh
what big news it is medically
uh we are so far ahead of uh can he list
the accomplishments today
he's a logistical standpoint and that's
the other thing we're also gearing up
and close to geared up because we have
tremendous people in the military
so they'll be able to deliver service
very rapidly so a lot of good things are
happening
and let's see what happens in the very
near future he says it's a big day
therapeutically vaccine what are the
what happened today like what
what happened being here we appreciate
how many people you employ as an
industry
and the special issues that we have and
we look forward to continuing to work
with you
good thank you very much how are you
doing on deductibility steve how's that
going good
good we're doing great thank you mr
president i
really appreciate you gathering us here
today this is a great representation of
restaurants from across the country
jose with his ten thousand my two on
bourbon street uh
i am the president ceo of galatoires
we've been there since 1905
and uh you know restaurants are the
cornerstone of so many communities
uh where some big big business is absent
restaurants are there
and we employ so many people we just
appreciate how swiftly y'all have acted
to bring relief our way we think with
just
a few small changes in cover period and
length of the cover period
on the forgiveness of ppp we have a real
great opportunity
and you know just the very nature of
restaurants
in general we rely on social interaction
so it makes us really unique that we
were hit hard
quickly uh and it's going to make our
comeback
really difficult uh that being said i'm
glad to hear
uh your news yeah that there there's
well my news uh
negates what you just said because you
would you would be back into business
like you had it
yeah no seats lost et cetera what so
yeah you'd we'll see what happens but uh
it certainly negates it yeah yeah so you
know
in the interim we appreciate the
opportunity
longer cure periods on the uh on the
test
test periods on the loans would be
incredible you know a city like new
orleans
we have 1500 restaurants but only 400
000 people
and so when you look at that where how
do we survive we survived with
with leisure and business travelers uh
19 million visitors last year
and and that being said uh you know
it's going to take us a little time to
ramp back up i guess trump doesn't know
we're looking forward uh to that period
of time
and uh and we believe that you guys have
the opportunity to to help us we greatly
appreciate it we've survived
uh hurricane katrina we've survived the
bp oil spill restaurant tours are a
resilient group
uh very tenacious and so
we we're we're there and we appreciate
your help so your area was amazing
because uh
it was hit hard but it was very late
we didn't think it was going to be hit
at all and then all of a sudden it
spiked up
after you had a certain event and who
knows what
caused it but maybe it was that yeah and
then it uh
it's doing incredibly well right now
it's really down at all yeah we've made
great progress the governor's done
a really good job that being said
25 capacity is tough to to to literally
think that this week when we reopen it
we'll lose more money than last week
because now we're incurring expenses
you got to get a hundred percent okay
let's get up and it's i hope it's going
to be up very fast i hope the governor
does that
pretty quickly let's see how it goes so
there's actually a lot has to do with
what i said in my opening remarks
very interesting ivanka do you have
anything to say
well i've spoken with many of the people
around this table over the course of the
past several weeks and and before
they all said the same thing why are you
here and why are we talking to you
the program has given restaurants alone
that industry
alone over 30 billion dollars
of relief representing a quarter of a
million restaurants nationwide
and that's just where we are today so
the feedback has been tremendously
helpful
the secretaries um made some changes and
to of course informing new policy um as
we come out of this but we really
appreciate your being here and we thank
you for the feedback
thank you honey thank you honey hi
mr president mr vice president secretary
all of you thank you for having us
uh my name is will gadara of 11 madison
park
in new york city um but i'm also a
founding member of the independent
restaurant coalition
um we started just so i think i've seen
this guy in a documentary about
about uh that restaurant together to
represent the 500
000 independent restaurants across
america i'm talking about
the mom and pops your local diner the
pizza place the pasta joint and the
three michelin star restaurant and
honestly
everything in between um the things that
represent
the cultural fabric of our cities and of
our towns and the things that i believe
as a country we need to fight to keep
we also represent the 11 million people
that work in those independent
restaurants
across the country um
listen it's clear that this
administration cares about our industry
and it's also clear that all of you
understand
the extent to which we are more
specifically vulnerable than a lot of
other industries in america
and i think that's why we're here today
and so
i think it's just important to take a
moment and acknowledge that and
and say thank you that we're taking this
time thank you will very much
thank you ppp is important and the
changes that have already been talked
about and are going to continue
being talked about today are very
important and if those changes are made
such that people
feel confident that they can spend that
money and have it forgiven i think that
will be the thing that allows our
restaurants to reopen
right that said we need something more
than that
that is specific to independent
restaurants in order for
our restaurants to stay open um
everyone here knows that last month
alone i think in the first half of april
more than one out of four people that
applied for unemployment were restaurant
workers
one out of four it's just insane
and so we've put forward a plan to
members of congress and to this
administration um that we
put forward because it'll put all of
those people that are currently
unemployed back to work
right such that by the third quarter of
this year we're going to be looking at
unemployment
reports that are astonishingly good
not to mention the supply chain that we
represent
if restaurants go down the commercial
real estate
industry the farming industry and so our
plan
helps bring unemployment back to where
it needs to be
and it supports a lot of our other
industries that rely on independent
restaurants for their survival
and so we appreciate being here we'd
love the opportunity to talk more about
this i know
that in times like this a lot of people
have their hands out i don't take that
lightly
i do believe that independent
restaurants are more vulnerable than
most
this guy's talking too much a really
important part of this nation
and i don't want to lose them and so we
appreciate your consideration and your
support
okay thank you very much will appreciate
it larry please
thank you sir um this is kudlow 48
states are opening
that's a big plus and the vaccination
research news is great today
so we see it in the stock market uh i
want to thank everybody for being here
we are working hard steve mentioned the
tax deductions for restaurants we're
also working very hard on the covet 19
liability restrictions that's going to
be a key part of our
next package and i just want to say i
guess i'm usually the optimist but
we're in a terrible pandemic contraction
here in the second quarter we know that
and there's a lot of hardship and a lot
of heartbreak
but there's also a few glimmers of hope
of recovery
because i know you sir believe in the
second half recovery and i do too and i
think with the right policies we can
have a booming next year but
the signs are housing demand looks
better gasoline demand looks better
the apple mobility index looks better
that's you know people dialing up to see
who's
where to get from a to b um new york
state's empire state
manufacturing index was up enormously i
don't know where that came from but it
was
unemployment claims each week looked
terrible but
they're a lot less terrible from you
know 7 million to 3 million
so there are some glimmers of hope kevin
has some data on
better credit card numbers so it's a
tough haul
but i think things are starting to turn
that's my take
i wish everybody luck i think so larry
maybe much more than people understand
and
you're starting to see that going to
come back strong
please mr president mr vice president
secretary scalia secretary i want to
thank you for having us here today
i have restaurants across the united
states we
average 27 employees per restaurant
these are the
small businesses across in each of these
communities that
those 27 people have families have
mortgages
have rents have car payments to make
every day
and being able to stay open and work
with the governors
and get the ppme money and to be able to
give people reassurances that tomorrow's
going to be better
than it was today and to give them that
hope has been really important for
us our business and those families and i
want to thank you for your leadership
and your team's leadership in doing so
one of the things we talk about
in the business is how well we we talk
about treating others and bringing
people into the family and bring them
into the restaurant like you bring them
into your home and that's what we do in
the restaurant business every day we
treat everyone like family
and doing so and having the leadership
here has been really helpful to us
and the entire industry and frankly uh
you know eight weeks nine weeks ago i
was thinking about this chinese
nightmare
and i didn't want it to affect the
american dream that we all had
and and i'm a a success story about the
american dream
going from 3 45 an hour starting at the
front counter in a fast food restaurant
to what we have today and i couldn't be
prouder how many how many restaurants
i own and operate 765 restaurants across
the united states fantastic
small business owner and it's uh i
couldn't be
it's an american dream sir and i
appreciate everything everyone's doing
here
to keep that dream going and the
tomorrow is going to be better today and
i appreciate that thank you
if we get deductibility you'll do better
than you did two months ago
thank you sir that's my opinion yes mr
president please
go ahead kevin give it let us let us
know what's going to happen
yeah uh sir uh you know first of all uh
you might recall when we first started
talking about the
economic damage that was coming from the
shutdown that we emphasized right from
the beginning
that this industry uh and the travel
industry were going to be the hardest
hit
and so we've been focused like a laser
beam on coming up with policy ideas to
do something about it and as you said
we've got a really good plan
the thing i could say is that if you
look at the real-time data as larry said
that you really are starting to see
glimmers of hope and maybe even like you
could even
characterize it a little more
optimistically than that larry's being
super cautious but the
credit card data are really going up the
number of businesses open in the country
is skyrocketing i mean the country's
getting back now and i think that
there's a great
reason look at the smirk on this guy's
face because you can really see things
going
much much faster forward than i expected
i i know you know i was
pretty depressed about how bad it looked
and how slow it was going to be a few
weeks ago but now you can really see it
turning on faster than i thought
is it tremendous demand tremendous
pent-up demand it's true
don't forget we turned it off
artificially you know it was just
stopped
we went from the greatest economy in
history of any country
right to we have to stop and we saved
by doing that millions of lives we saved
hundreds of thousands but probably
millions of lives
and we did the right thing and now we
have to open and now we're gonna
do great and if we uh if this comes
along what we're hearing uh
medically from these great companies
these geniuses if this
happens uh that's really uh that's
really going to be something
so a great job thank you thank you
please
mr vice president secretary scalia
secretary mnuchin
it's an honor to be here today my name
is marvin irby
and on behalf of the national restaurant
association thank you
for convening this meeting these
industry leaders on this very important
subject
to be honest with you normally at this
time i'd spend a lot of time telling you
about this industry
but what's been clear over the last
several months is that you get it
this administration gets it you know
everything
about our world-famous chefs your god
our esteemed independence
our beloved brands that dot every
community in this country
and i'm proud to say that for over 100
years the national restaurant
association
has represented all restaurants they
play a key role
in our society in an integral role in
our food chain
i have the opportunity that i get to
speak to restaurateurs every single day
and i can confirm we desperately want to
reopen
our restaurants are desperate and are
heartbroken and at this time we can't
provide the support
and the comfort to the communities in
which we serve
right for too many restaurants right now
this incident happened 60 days ago that
has crippled us
and before today's news we did not see
an
end date until later this year
programs like the paycheck protection
program are an incredible first step
and thank you secretary mnuchin for
this program which has benefited
millions of small companies throughout
this country
[Music]
we also appreciate ivanka trump's
dedication to our industry
and i personally want to thank you for
the time you've taken to talk to our
board
over the last months of this crisis
mr president the payroll protection
program would be a godsend
if we could make one change if we could
extend the time
that we need that we have to spend the
proceeds
in too many communities today the
eight-week period is simply not
enough time so how much how much time
are you on
24 weeks about 30 weeks 30 weeks works
30 weeks works how about 75 weeks i know
a couple of you
you'll never stop right uh-oh i know a
couple of this is how trump negotiates
now i understand so you think it needs
to be what would you say would be a
minimum length
24 weeks how much 24 weeks
you need to give our smaller restaurants
areas the opportunities
to open to begin to have demand and
bring back
the employees is that what were you
going to say in terms of timing
yeah i think for the ppp fixes if we
could take it from eight weeks to 24
weeks
is that the no is that the time yeah
more or less the term you're thinking
about
and then move june 30th to october 31st
if those two changes were made to that
program it would
change it dramatically deductibility
that yes deductibility is
amazing but it's almost like
we need to build the house first
deductibility is the thing that makes
the house does anybody disagree with
that because i think deductibility is
the biggest thing you can possibly do
is anybody i think that if you if what
he's saying is
if we could get the 24 weeks which gets
us to october 31st basically right
this is great this allows us to to get
the young restaurateurs
going and spend the money that you
intended for them so that we can
get out and show them what a great job
you guys are doing but you're pretty
unified on the number 24
yeah 24. okay go ahead please
the best thing about it is no additional
money
it's an extension of the current program
okay so the deductibility thing is great
can i just i just don't want to not
support that i think it's just a matter
of waiting
we we need to get the restaurants open
first and these changes allow us to it's
absolutely clear that that's true
i just wanted to clarify because you
said it's no additional money are you
saying just the time period
because it's eight weeks going to 24.
you still have eight weeks of money or
you want 24 weeks of money
oh no we want 24 weeks in order to spend
to spend the eight weeks correct got it
thank you for the clarification
we we believe that if we elongate is
that correct does everybody agree with
that
yes sir if we can elongate the test
period
it gives us more staying power and we
can spend that money
uh and this is interesting trump's
obsessed with the deductibility thing
which i can explain to you guys later
everybody else is like we just want more
time to spend this money
because remember the whole issue is
there's a certain point at which you
have to start
paying it's it's no longer forgivable
and and you start paying interest on it
and that's what they're talking about
here
payroll tax i would say deductibility
payroll tax deductions all those things
are spectacular and we need them and
they would be
greatly beneficial but we're viewing the
ppp fix as what we need
to so the ppp was really a big deal yes
sir
so we hit it right when we did it we hit
it right okay thank you very much
thank you such a big deal am i doing
wrong
it was such a big deal sir that we
haven't laid off a single person and
there's 20 000 people that are paying
their
taxes they're paying their bills and
they're doing all that every day
and without that i don't think we would
have been able to do that sir that's how
big a deal it is
great wow
i do see folks signing up by the way i i
will mention everybody after this
mr president mr vice president good
afternoon thank you so much for your
leadership
ladies and gentlemen it's an honor to be
here
and i deeply appreciate the opportunity
my name is niren i represent panera
bread
panera has two and a half thousand cafes
there's another
revenues of about six billion dollars
and we employ 140 000 people
the pandemic impacted us very deeply as
it did everybody else
we lost close to 50 of our revenue in
the first week
since then it is slowly coming back but
we still have a
long way to go now the health crisis you
got
down by 50 or more than that uh
50 to 60 was the revenue decline that's
not bad
and uh we are and i think what's what's
good is that it's actually coming back
uh since that time thanks to a lot of
the
innovation that we've been able to do
but so you got maximum though 50 percent
of revenue losses yeah
how'd you keep the other 50 so the the
50
that we have by ensuring so fortunately
i think in panera we have very strong
omni-channel business right so we have
delivery
rapid pickup drive through you did very
well so on that's good
great job go ahead yeah so i think we've
had to innovate very quickly and i'll
share some uh some of those ideas
so um i believe that the health crisis
is now becoming a financial crisis you
know with 36 million americans
unemployed and
a humanitarian crisis as well with about
54 million americans
fighting hunger and therefore i think
opening up the economy
right now in a phased manner is the
right thing to do i also believe
that we as leaders need to also step up
and do the right thing
at this time and do what we can do
what's in our control
and i'll share some ideas and thoughts
in terms of what panera has been doing
largely with the the intent to innovate
and do that with compassion and heart so
for our furloughed employees
you know we have free family meals every
week for them
emergency relief funds and also we've
made arrangements with peer companies
at this time like cvs walmart
to hire our followed employees
temporarily and then return them back
for customers we've innovated very
quickly we've launched the curbside
pickup service with geofencing and also
free wi-fi outside the cafes because
life is moving
to outside the cafes and also uh
doing a lot for our communities
especially those impacted most by the
pandemic
so doctors and nurses we are serving
about 50 000 meals to doctors and nurses
in new york
children in the state of ohio with our
partnership with usda and also
uh we've launched a program called
together without hunger
with feeding america and have pledged to
serve half a million meals to children
and families
uh through through feeding america right
so i think it's very important at this
time that i think we need to also step
up
and contribute we were able to keep 85
percent of our cafes open
we were determined to keep them open so
that we could keep our associates
employed at that time and therefore now
we're beginning to
open up the dining areas and phases
following all the guidelines but also
have
stringent protocols that we've put in
place like
plexiglas barriers wellness stations for
temperature checks
social distancing norms etc
i think we're keeping any of that i mean
there are some innovations that have
been made some people say maybe we'll
keep it
would you be keeping any of that or not
really yes we i think this is there's
going to be a shift
in how the consumers are going to
interact with brands and i think it is
time for
for us to innovate so another example is
would you ever keep the
plexid less barriers so i think we'll
keep the plexiglas barriers
let me on a permanent basis i'm talking
about i think at least
over the next six to nine months but
could you see that being
permanent because hopefully you're not
going to have to have it that long by
the way nine months
but would you see a thing like that
you'd have to build a nicer version of
it
you know as opposed to quickly throwing
it up but would you see something like
that being permanent possibly
i think hopefully if the virus is under
control and we've gotten to the other
side of it
and then we can bet get back to life as
we once knew we'd rather not have it
we'd rather move back to life as we
wanted right rather i agree
yeah i agree exactly okay and another i
think
interesting innovation is that
recognizing that there's so
so much high friction with high demand
grocery items where you can't get them
home delivered
we launched a new line of business
called panera grocery in 10 days
and we deliver trump's not like in this
items fresh produce dairy to customers
in less than an hour on the same day
so i think the good thing is it's forced
us to really innovate and be very
responsive
good i think the restaurant industry is
deeply deeply appreciative
of all the support and the efforts that
you and the administration have made
i think the cares act has been huge it
is a bit much by the way whenever
a lot of people are taking you know 15
seconds a minute two minutes for this
guy to go on like this it's a little bit
out of place
it's i think with a few of the
amendments that we talked about i'd
fully
uh agree with the eight weeks to 24
weeks i think that is badly needed i
think that will be hugely
uh welcomed steve does that make sense
from our standpoint what do you think
um we're working on a technical fix that
we do have bipartisan support for to
extend it i'm not sure it's that long
but
i've spoken to the sba committee and
there is
bipartisan support so we're working on
that and i think we talked about the
limited liability i think that's also
very important aspect and thirdly
the democrats don't want to give you
like the liability
provision they just don't want to have
that and it's crazy that they don't but
the democrats do not want to give that
to people and that's not a good thing
and i think the uh the third thing is
anyway
go ahead the our employees are i think
if we can eliminate the friction
in the forward employees being able to
access the unemployment benefits
that will also be fantastic and uh and
that the problem there is the states
have old equipment in many cases and
they're unable to get the money you know
we
gave the money out immediately but the
states are running some states are
unable to give it out they have 40 year
old equipment
yeah and some states are unable to get
their act together
but we gave that out long ago as you
probably know yeah okay
i appreciate it thank you very much
thank you very much brooke would you
like to say a few words
mr president thank you just a few words
i am uh i am so grateful for all of you
being here today i am struck
by the stories of true american dreams i
mean starting at 3 45 an hour
and then ultimately owning so many
restaurants and hundreds of thousands
but i'm also hundreds of thousands of
employees
but i'm also streaming by this president
and vice president's commitment
to our most vulnerable populations
and their american dream and their
american dream working in
all of your restaurants this president
is the jobs president i think that
none of us other than maybe uh true
nobody's lost more jobs than trump
economy that we would achieve in just
three short years
where there were more people more jobs
available than people to fill them
and what i am so encouraged by is the
resoluteness and the conviction
of this president this vice president
but but truly the american entrepreneurs
that are sitting around the table today
and working alongside all of you as we
bring this country back
to even greater heights than we ever
knew possible the transition to
greatness
is is really what america and the
american dream is all about so thank you
all
for being here know that we are here to
help you always and we are here to make
sure that
what this president led on and has
achieved will be once again
very very soon so thank you mr president
thank you very much great job
[Music]
thank you mr president mr vice president
and secretary for having me here today
my name is tim love i'm a chef and owner
of a few restaurants
in texas and tennessee uh i also am the
chef of
four major music festivals and food
festivals around the country
um so i've been greatly affected by
obviously what's happened here along
with everybody else in this room
but what i wanted to speak to you about
today is that to touch on the ppp and to
kind of clarify what
what we were saying is the 24 weeks is
only set up because certain restaurants
aren't able to open now
in texas we were able to open on may 1st
and i quickly activated the ppp
and tried to get all my employees back
i've hired 80 of my workforce i started
with 490 employees
we've got about 400 employees already
back and i will say it's encouraging to
see people come out they're excited they
want to be out
what would have happened if you didn't
have ppp
well if i didn't would you have survived
it would you have gotten by
i'll probably have gotten by but that
this allows us to do it the way that
we feel like it should be to take care
of the employees first we want to take
care of our employees
and make sure they're safe same same
activation we're having opening the
restaurants we want to open the
restaurant safely
make sure our employees are safe first
so our guests can be safe
i i'd ask from the administration to put
out that confidence
to get the american people understanding
that it is great to go out
and that our economy is going to be
great again because we know where it was
before it started we know how how to get
there clearly
so now just with a couple of adjustments
to things that
are already written now to the
secretary's point we don't need
we're not asking for more money we're
just asking an opportunity to spend it
the way that you want us to spend it
the way it was intended to take care of
our employees when we're able to open up
that's it that should be easy steve
honestly yes sir mr president i think i
think you can
you can take care of that for sure we're
working on it that should be easy yes mr
president yes
and uh so it's like one of the easiest
requests i've ever heard larry
well that that leads me to at least my
next request
the uh the 75-25 the way that it's spent
i know it's tough
but i'm speaking for my friends who are
in new york not necessarily for myself
even in texas where the rents are higher
and they need the ability to spend the
money on rent if necessary so long as
they're hiring their employees back
so while the number one thing is to get
the workforce back
reduce unemployment get people back to
work which is what i'm doing at 25
believe me i'm not going and building
new houses on my 25 percent of occupancy
but what i am doing
is putting the great american people
back to work that i love trump even know
what
the economy going is getting the workers
back to work so they're able to spend
money and earn money
so therefore we can keep the economy
moving and so those two adjustments
to the ppp which which you know don't
require any extra money from the
administration
from congress allows us to really move
the economy forward which i know is one
of your number one things
especially as we're moving along this
year and i think you can get a lot of
people in our industry
the workers that people work very very
hard to get behind you
just to show that kind of confidence i
think you will how many restaurants are
there total
everything in the united states how many
are there
how much 650 000 restaurants who would
who would think that's 11 of the overall
650 000 restaurants who would ever think
that's possible even right all right
that's good and it's been a great
business over the years and it'll be
better than 650
000 again so long as you can experience
you're doing this yeah no it's so i
think deductibility gets that actually i
think you'll i would agree with that
very substantially they got rid of a lot
of restaurants when they ended that
people don't realize that then you get
used to it you had fewer restaurants
they rented to other things now i don't
know what they're going to rent to
and to your point about that sir the the
deductibility which
you can easily identify with and it and
it does spread wealth amongst
restaurants
most definitely we're talking just about
an immediate
concern with the ppp to get people
moving forward so that we can get this
deductibility going no i agree we'll
look at that very strongly yes sir thank
you
okay hello mr president and
uh it sees how important this it is to
all of you all this subject because i
haven't seen this much firepower from
all of you all except at a state dinner
or
uh a christmas party so i appreciate mr
what on earth
president that all of you guys are here
because i know you're
really trying to get something done um i
own a company landry's which is in 40
states
and it's all full-service restaurants so
i average
like 150 employees per restaurant and
it's everything from del frisco's to
mastros to martin's the palm but then
it's
on the other side the bubba gumps the
rainforest
and they're all company owned um
this it's been devastating you know it's
funny you brought up about china i
should have realized it was going to be
a bad year for china when my general
manager tweeted out
you know freedom for hong kong so that
started my
my year with china
so i'm still trying to work that out
what is happening and here comes
something else he owns the houston
rockets certification
and he's a great and by the way he's a
great guy great family great everything
and
uh yeah he did cause you little ruckus
whatever happened to him yeah is he
still working for you yes he is he must
be pretty good yes
because uh it's just uh it's a trick
question
but he is so so but but but mr
president everybody's talking about the
ppp and the
when when uh your team designed the ppp
and said let's bring it through through
the sba i think it was an
unbelievable idea and you did exactly
what you needed to do
but i'm one of those people when it
started being pitted against
because i'm a sole proprietor but i do 4
billion in revenue and i would have been
that billionaire that took the money
from the little business
so i was not able to take the ppp money
and i caught so much criticism because i
was the first person who did lay off
forty thousand employees
because the world doesn't understand
that when you shut everything down
uh from your casinos which you and i did
are
what is together from the rainforest to
the trump arena
um your tail of your payroll was 150
million dollars the next two weeks and
we all pay
yesterday's bills with today's income
and and uh i wanted to put 40 000 people
back to work maybe i feel really bad for
this guy
guys i mean it's just terrible the
situation this guy's in the criticism
and even from the administration there
was some that bigger companies
shouldn't be by the way what is a
rainforest cafe i don't have the ability
to put those 40 000 people back to work
is he simultaneously saying that as a
rich dude he shouldn't get the money but
also that trump should have helped him
figure out how to keep the 40
like what is his argument on restaurants
and you have it yourself
yeah that it would have been one person
taking this money but your team
specifically wrote the bill
for any restaurant under 500. this was
for the restaurant business
which has only got nine percent of the
money but if you would just
split it up and i'm not saying add any
more money but add a category for the
the larger private restaurant tour that
could go out and take this money
and put it in a different bucket so it
wouldn't be me taking this money away
from the little beauty so what happened
to you then tillman so
where are you on that whole thing how
did you do with the
uh how did you how did it work out for
your company i
took the money and sent it back and did
not spend
a dollar of it because because they
found out you're very rich and they said
what the hell you know what but i also
was the first person that opened the
leverage finance market and went and
borrowed 300 million
at 12 where just three months earlier
borrowed it three percent
because i needed the liquidity out of
the room
keep the company afloat so so what do
you do you went out very early right
for the money and you you found the
market were it was opened even at that
early days yes i borrowed 300 million
uh to add to liquidity but i still it
wasn't enough
to to 300 million that he was able to
borrow on credit was not enough guys
with the ppp what did you do with your
basketball players that are making 25
million a year
uh i have two of them that make 40. um
uh russell and james by the way
they are good players they are good but
they uh yes they are getting paid is a
collective bargaining agreement
and that's why what's going to happen
with basketball can you give us a
because i wouldn't be interested do you
have any idea what they're doing yes
yes i think what they're doing is is
waiting to see what happens in certain
states and if we're going to be able to
play
making sure the virus continues to go in
the in the right direction in the next
few weeks
and and i think that if things keep
going the way that it's going i think
which of these people are high right now
adam silver who's done an unbelievable
job through this
and and the 30 the owners i think will
make the decision to try to start the
season up again
will you finish the season or not i
think that there's talk about
uh finishing the season playing x amount
of games
the the players need to play to to get
paid and right now they're taking a 25
pay cut oh god and because they they own
50 of our revenues the players unlike
the other
sports and so they they want that
revenue and that television revenue
even if it's not the the people in the
stands revenue
so they have anyone ever seen a whinier
billionaire i mean just
whiny in the traditional sense of the
word i think that
we would play some games just to to get
it going again
and create the interest and then go
right into the playoffs but i think
it'll be great for america we're all
missing sports and
everybody you know other than trump
obviously what an idiot i am other than
trump has anybody seen a whiny or
billionaire
away for us mr secretary
steve what do you think about that i
mean he's got a unique situation you
know he has
a lot of restaurants it's a big company
but you know but i can't pay you have
other people where the company is the
same size but you have 2 000 owners
what do you think of that well
it's a complicated issue mr president as
i've said before we we didn't anticipate
the los angeles lakers who i'm a big fan
of
would be taking the ppp loan and as a
result of that there was a lot of
backlash
we paid it back we went through this i'm
saying that for the media they
again we realize the issue how it
impacts your workers and we're
sympathetic to that
uh this was a program for uh
companies that were not necessarily
quite as big but
yeah but this is different than the
lakers the lakers are a basketball team
there's a man that owns
many how many restaurants you own 600
restaurants but they're all
full service restaurants you know i have
60 000 employees and
and uh and you don't have the ability to
pay him
they've got to move on from this dude
this is really cringe
no but it is interesting for the press
to hear it because they understand the
complexity of it
so if he had 600 owners and he
franchised them out or something but he
had 600 owners
they qualify if he has you know if he
owns it
it's a different situation but i can
understand what he's saying
so let's take a look at it and then just
one more thing if we could just do
something with least terminations
because like
i'm the largest operator in new york for
full service reference and the
million-dollar leases
let them protect their rights the
landlord what's your largest restaurant
what is it
del frisco's mastros martins the strip
house the
bills burger and rockefeller center you
know uh
dos caminos you know on and on so
but but this guy's got to have some
sense slapped into him am i right
hit by the plague right but
uh outside of that you've done a hell of
a job just trying to keep it
just brought you back to earth a little
bit absolutely we were definitely
brought back to earth
you really have you've done a fantastic
job this guy to gerbil voice jared now
say yeah you paid me rent for a long
time right
never missed a payment and you were
never late now
you're a tough landlord a great
gentleman really a great gentleman see
if it's an interesting case okay
uh do the best you can good luck with
the basketball thank you sir you have a
hell of a team
and thank you thank you all of you say
hello to those two great players all of
your players but
man they are they can play huh they can
play so you say they make 40 a year
uh russell and james both make 40
million a year
and they were still getting paid so a
lot of my employees really wanted that
ppp money
you want them to you want them to play
this it's not really funny
how many more years you have together
right the nba players are fine but then
this guy's got 40 grand he wants a
handout from the government 40 000
he wants to hand out from the government
in order to keep on sudden you get a big
ring
good luck thanks tillman thank you sir
i just want to thank everyone for being
here it's been incredible to watch all
the innovations that you've been doing
in your business models to give more
confidence to the public to get open
the president identified this very early
as a critical industry for us to focus
on
uh for a few reasons one is you're a
major employer there's a lot of people
who are
hurting right now because the restaurant
industry is closed but also you're a gem
of america people love
city entertainment enjoyment from the
great work that you do
so this has never really been an issue
before because the restaurant business
has never been closed before for a
period of time so this is
truly a unique historical uh situation
that's occurred and you know we're all
in this together to try to figure out
the best way back but
the quicker that we can help you figure
out how to get demand up the quicker you
could hire back employees and
we can get jared's such a big boy
establishment so thank you for all
you're doing and thank you mr president
for your leadership
so you know tillman he took a ventilator
job where the country basically had no
ventilators
essentially and built an incredible
empire for building ventilators in a
period of
very short time and now we're supplying
ventilators all over the world
it's an amazing thing we got no credit
from the fake news media but what are
you going to do can't win them all
and now with the testing today on the
washington post
they actually had a headline that the
testing is there but the people
aren't there we have so much testing i'm
sure the person that drew that headline
in the washington post will be fired
today sometime mr president
in the state in the state of texas i
know for
for six weeks any employee of mine could
go
to numerous places and get tested
and not even stand in line so when i
watch and see everything
that people cannot get tested in america
and i don't know about all the other
states but i do have employees that have
been tested in other states
i just follow it closer there has not
been an issue of people getting tested
and you know they sort of knew it but
and we were even tested here
i think i think you should be entitled
to that now steve definitely
yeah no we we've done really it's been
an amazing 100 percent been an amazing
job
been an amazing job we made a lot of
governors look good
mr president i will say yesterday uh you
had your number one day in america 422
thousand tests performed and
uh you're about 11.5 million tests
performed now in the u.s thanks to your
leadership
numbers that would have been your number
one day i would say that can you imagine
numbers that would have been john those
are numbers that could have been
talked about nobody would have believed
it so anyway
you know so please mr president
like yourself i'm a new yorker and a
career changer
i was a former bond trader at goldman
sachs and now i own restaurants in
brooklyn most notably lilia and missy
in williamsburg we help make every day
good day
along with thomas and will we're
founding members of the independent
restaurant
coalition and we're grateful to have a
seat at this table for the first time
the impact catalyzed by this pandemic is
enormous the prolonged
economic shutdown created challenges for
our industry
that has to be met with policy to inject
liquidity investment
consumption and hiring the immediate and
coordinated response by your
administration
to support out-of-work employees was
inspiring
and it should make us all proud to be
americans the intention of ppp
to support small businesses and
restaurants
was pragmatic and encouraging we have
all agreed
that it wasn't perfect but
we're working on it to fix it so that it
could help us
but we need those fixes now like me
i have it i can't use it i'm in the
clock zone of
eight weeks ppp is a bridge
so do you agree with what they're saying
in terms of timing
immediately it must happen and you agree
with the 24 number yes
absolutely did you guys meet before this
or something
no did you have a little meeting to
discuss this perhaps
well now i feel better because
everyone's exactly what is the same
thing what is
what is incredible about this
independent restaurant coalition
this did not exist seven weeks ago
restaurant owners didn't talk to each
other
ever and we bring people together yeah
it's amazing what trump
trump's been able to allow coronavirus
to be bad enough that these guys now
have a relationship that's beautiful
thing i'm only kidding we've been able
to we've been able to talk we'd be
able to be creative and figure out ways
to bring this that's great
i think it's great you got together and
a lot of good suggestions have been made
and it's been made uniformly so we
really know your opinion as opposed to
having all different ideas that's
correct that's really great so ppp
is a bridge it will help restaurants
reopen our doors
it'll help restaurants re-employ 11
million
workers that are currently not working
in an effort to keep those doors open
and to keep our people employed we
propose
a stabilization plan and we look forward
to discussing more in the future with
you
okay thank you very much thank you great
how did you go from goldman sachs to the
restaurant business how did that happen
david solomon didn't think i was very
good at bond trading oh but you were
i'll bet you were very good
um okay are you glad you made that move
i am
it's changed my life for the better on
everything ever you love the restaurant
business right i love it
i have friends that are in the
restaurant they love the rest there's no
business they want to go into
right we view you as one of us yeah uh
that's weird yeah no it's great i know
your business very well
people uh unlike well you know there are
other businesses but just about as much
as any business they love
being in the restaurant business so
that's great it's it's good to get out
there so you made a good move
oh yes did you make a good move
financially i did
very very well it worked out fine too
our restaurants are more profitable than
the hedge fund that i worked at
for seven years wow that's fantastic
that's scary now we don't have to give
them anything
but but i want to go back to that
because i want to reopen
as soon as possible yeah now i agree
with it okay great
good good job too i know the the one
restaurant i know it's great
thank you very much uh gene this is a
man of great genes
his name is gene and his father was a
terrific gentleman you know that right
great talent
go ahead please be a great mother too
right uh maybe your mother's even better
well there uh are few industries where
the workers
have been hit as hard as in this
particular industry as well was touching
on
uh we announced uh 20.5 million
payroll job losses basically from the
middle of march the middle of april
and 5.5 million of those more than a
quarter were
in restaurants mr president uh you saw
this coming you acted with
really extraordinary speed and i think
as we said generosity
among other things in the unemployment
benefit that was provided in the cares
act uh we at the labor department have
been working extremely hard with the
states to enable them to make that
payment as you touched on they've had
they've had some problems because
of their competitors secretary and i
cautioned
the congress that there would be
problems but we will continue to work
with them to get those payments out
but but even as we do that we know that
we're pivoting we're opening
uh we're reopening across the country
it's it is uh there are
uh glimmers and more than that as as we
begin that reopening and so we will be
focusing too
on helping workers transition from
unemployment
back onto the job and you hear a lot of
numbers a number that really sticks with
me is a couple different surveys have
shown
federal surveys have shown that 90 of
workers
who are unemployed right now have said
it's temporary
and i want to make that right i want to
make that true that's why mr president
you want to
safely but but promptly reopen and so
we'll continue to work with that's a
very important number 90
if you go into a real big recession and
you don't have a number like that that's
a tremendous number
that's really a great it's a it's a
testament because again it was
artificially turned on
and off but now it's off and we're going
to turn it back on it's been turned on
as of
i don't know it almost feels like today
is the first day i think last week
didn't feel the same now it feels good
people are starting to go out they're
opening
they get it we understand the disease
much better than we did
when it first came in nobody understood
it nobody's ever seen it before
and it feels much different i mean
today's almost like the first day
but uh the expression that we like to
use right transition to greatness we're
going to be back
and what you said is a very important
thing people
expect to go back and by moving quickly
but safely
we we get them there and i had uh
discussions with several of you about
about safety we're very focused on that
at the labor department
giving workers and i know you're focused
too on giving customers the confidence
as they return and we'll
we'll continue to work with cdc and
others to help on that front and gene
you have to help the truckers also
we've been talking about the truckers mr
president because they've been out there
and i'll tell you they're
they work hard and they have brokers
that take a lot of their business away
they don't work so hard
they sit in an office someplace it's not
good so i'd i'd like to help the
truckers yeah elaine and i have been
talking all right
good please beautiful
mr president um secretary vice president
pence
secretary scalia thank you for having us
today of course
i'll echo what everybody else has said
how proud we are um
to be sitting here at the white house in
your home
uh to be able to share some of our
struggles and and hopes and aspirations
um the restaurant profession is a
profession that's always dynamic
and you've seen that around this table
with some of the things that my
colleagues are doing
but we're also very united uh as you've
seen and you just responded to
the the 24 weeks um did we have a
meeting before certainly we had a
meeting before did we talk about it
certainly we talked about it
um because we want to be unified uh in
our approach whether you have
650 restaurants two restaurants six
restaurants
thousand restaurants it doesn't really
matter we all are nurturers at heart
and we want our restaurants to reopen uh
so that they can
uh nurture our guests our communities uh
and finally our country
um there's something to be said for
going last because i just want to agree
with everything that everybody else has
said around this table
so i won't i won't repeat it and boris
with uh with more of the same
but i will tell you a a a story a
personal story two personal stories if i
may oh no uh one about the ppp
and thank you very much because it's
been a lifesaver
uh in many ways for me i have
restaurants of course where i have not
been able to use the ppp yet
um but i also have uh because we can't
open yet
um and there's no point in me hiring
back by the staff where
um california new york uh las vegas and
south florida i mean i hear they're
gonna keep
los angeles closed till the end of
august
is that a fact that's a good question
i'm i'm i'm in napa valley but
i'm not really sure about los angeles
i'm sorry
that's the mayor wants to do that okay
that's a death wish
because you know there's death on both
sides you know that that's from staying
home
not just a one-way street and we solved
a big problem but
you have to understand the other side of
it too and they don't understand the
other side of it
yeah okay on the other hand um our
consumer product good division where we
have four different businesses
has been thriving um and we have taken
our ppp money
and then we hired a hundred percent of
the staff in in those four companies so
i i look at that and i'm extremely
thankful and grateful for all the work
that you and your team have done
uh so quickly to help us um on our
restaurant side i echo what everybody
else is that's it's a little more more
complicated
um i also want to thank you for um
voicing your support
of big which is our business uh
interruption group which uh i started
with a couple other chefs
and has grown quite large um and we've
started to make some
inroads with with the insurance
companies certainly with some of the
congressmen and some of the senators so
we continue to work on that for all
businesses not just
for restaurant businesses finally i just
want i want to talk about
a small farm in orwell vermont
a small farmer named diane sinclair who
is by herself with her husband
and this is about the supply chain and
how important restaurants are
in in so many different aspects but we
reduce it down to
individuals that we know that we love
that depend on us
as as restaurateurs and as chefs it's a
woman who has eight cows who gets up
every morning
seven days a week to milk her cows let
them out the pasture begin to make her
butter
bring her cows back at four or five
o'clock milk them again and put them to
bed
every day i am i am the sole source of
her
revenue um she's not able to what a
dynamic
compelling and inspirational speaker
the impact that restaurants have in our
in our communities
in our states and in our country are
extraordinary
we are in many cases the first job
people have
my first job was in a restaurant as a
dishwasher making a little less than 350
but that was the best of my age um and
and being able to move up we are the
we give people the second chance in
restaurants
and finally people's last jobs are in
restaurants those who
are retired and on and on on benefits
um are augmenting their benefits by
working in restaurants
we don't really care about your
education we're not concerned about
where you come from can't retire so
you're working in a restaurant
at age 80. that's is that is that a
dystopian story or an inspirational
story
what does it say about social security
it's uh single-parent women's
um it's just extraordinary um how
how much we embrace our entire country
and what we do and what we do at heart
is we nurture i became a chef and i
remember the day i decided to become a
chef i'd been cooking for several years
july 1977 in narragansett rhode island
working for a french chef named roland
hennen
who asked me one day why do cooks cook
and i was certainly intimidated i was
young and as a chef
i don't know why do cooks cook he said
we cook to nurture people
and there was something inside of me
that that resonated with and i embraced
the idea
and nurturing people and i have 1200
employees
um there are over right so how many died
today and how close are we to the
vaccine today that i desperately want to
bring back
to work so that we can not only nurture
each other but nurture those who come
into our restaurants
again i want to thank you for for having
us here today i want to thank all my
colleagues
for for articulating everything that we
wanted to say
uh in in in in such a profound way um
and i appreciate the opportunity so
thank you mr president
thank you very much beautiful story with
the woman with the eight cows
you wouldn't think that restaurant tours
do especially i guess
some with an individual restaurant or a
couple of restaurants they do that a lot
don't they they buy directly
they do yeah we support so many small
farms
around the country i started an
initiative called big hearts and small
farms
with five other chefs just so that we
can offer people an opportunity to buy
some of the uh some of the food from
some of these small farms around the
country
tillman doesn't do that i don't think
you do that with your eight cows right
he doesn't know it's
a little different but you know it goes
from the very small to the very big and
that's what restaurants are all about
and i'm proud to be part of this
community
what's the difference in butter tell me
the difference in butter between what
she sells you
and what you would normally be able to
buy at a curiosity i don't want it it is
extraordinary because it is
truly a seasonal product so the butter
changes flavor and color
depending on the season so in the early
in the spring when they're eating green
when they're grazing on groceries
the butter is beautiful orange hue and
of course in the summer time it turns
lighter because they're eating hay
so mike just said there's no comparison
he knows
it's just yeah there's a scout
a tremendous difference oh and you
probably pay less
well i don't know how much i pay it's
not about how much i pay it's about
supporting her and what she's trying to
do
right but would you pay less generally
speaking when you do those things you do
directly with the phone you know
artisanal handmade butter is going to be
more than getting that
stuff from cisco food supply quality
because we're about quality
and building relationships with people
building i've been buying
diane's better for for for over 20 years
no kidding um she
she did tell me one time um i'll tell
you a little story again if i can
oh my god she had to raise the price of
her butter and i said diane i really
don't know how much your butter costs
but i appreciate you telling me this
issues but i also want to tell you
why and i said okay tell me why diane
she said my son was accepted at nyu
and i need to pay for his tuition this
is what happens when a guest goes into a
restaurant and spends a dollar
you're supporting all of these people
you're supporting this young man
who's going to get a degree from nyu do
i
do my should i should i should i you
know negotiate with her on price
yeah no i think it's great thank you
very much beautiful thank you
okay mike i think i think the media
wants us to go quickly
i'll go very quickly he wants to hit us
with a question so
well uh thank you mr president and uh um
i have had the great privilege of
sitting
in this room alongside the president
many occasions over the last three and a
half years i don't know that i've
ever been more inspired by the optimism
the resilience
the love of what you do and the people
that you employ and the people that you
serve that i've been today so
thank you all for sharing your stories
the president has brought together here
the our top economic team
secretary of the treasury secretary of
the labor all the people that have been
involved in standing up the whole of
government
uh response um but you guys think this
works like
will doing this and just not talking
about
the virus and what's going on and
stopping the spread and
how long can this work i just don't i
don't i don't know that i understand the
stress
i understand the strategy i question how
long it can work maybe it can work for a
long time i don't know
my friend considers himself to be one of
you uh and he always will
and but he understood when we asked the
american people
and we asked businesses like the
thousands represented here
to shut down to to go to drive through
services to find ways to innovate
to meet your customers we knew the
sacrifices that were involved in that
the president directed our economic team
to find a way paycheck protection
uh to stand up and come alongside but
your decision
your company's decision to put the
health of your employees
the health of your customers the health
of your community first
saved lives and you are to be commended
on behalf of the president
and all of us who've worked seven days a
week on this issue here at the national
level i want to say thank you
president i are going to dismiss in a
few minutes and we're going to go to our
weekly call with america's governors
and i'm proud as the president is that
as we sit here today 48 states have
announced plans to
reopen it was a month ago the president
had our task force release a plan to
open up america again
and america is opening back up and i
just want to assure you
that the council that you have given us
today will continue to inform ways that
we can
support not just this industry and the
communities but
support your state's efforts to safely
and responsibly
reopen and put america back to work one
last thing mr president
one of the great success stories of this
pandemic
has been that the food supply has not
been
interrupted and i honestly didn't know
mr president before
we got into this that roughly half of
america's food needs
are met in restaurants and in those 650
000 establishments that we're talking
about here today
and through this pandemic not only did
you innovate you found ways to continue
to meet that
food need and keep food on the table of
americans
but i also heard just a week ago that it
was restaurants that were transferring
what you had
in storage to your local grocery stores
to your local food banks to make sure
that
americans didn't miss any meals in the
course of this pandemic so for all those
reasons i say thank you
and just know that in this president and
in this entire team
we are going to be partners with you and
we're going to bring
back america and all of america's great
restaurants
bigger and better than ever before and
it's going to be sooner than you think
mike what are the two states that did
not open
um 48 states have released plans
uh there's two that are uh we expect
them to be releasing plans very soon who
are they
i'll get that to you before we talk to
the governors
is connecticut can't do anything
so it'll open it'll happen quickly so
just
uh briefly the paycheck protection
program
has delivered over 30 billion dollars in
aid to more than 250 000 restaurants
up to 95 of that funding is going
directly to the workers payroll you know
that
on friday the sba published the loan
forgiveness application
which ensures that all businesses
including restaurants will not be
penalized as long as they make good
faith
efforts to rehire all of their employees
you know that
i signed a bill providing federally
funded pay
to sick people people that are sick and
for family leave so you have for sick
and family leave and that's
a very important bill so you have
federally funded
paid sick and family leave and i think
some of you are taking advantage of that
businesses can defer paying
income taxes until july 15th
we gave that extension business can
claim tax refunds by deducting their
losses from the
2018 through 2020 against taxes they
paid
for the previous five years that's a big
deal
and then as you know we're going to
congress and this is uh
more pertinent to what we're talking
because you knew all of what i just said
you've been
living through it restore the restaurant
deduction to help jobless
restaurant workers so if a company pays
or somebody pays they get a deduction
that's going to create
a tremendous amount of business i think
you're going to have to open a lot of
additional restaurants in this country i
think it's
frankly more important than even the
other things we're talking about i guess
short term what you're talking about
everyone else disagrees but long term
the deduction would be phenomenal create
an explore america
that's explore right explore america tax
credit
that americans can use for domestic
travel including visits to restaurants
that's a big deal grant restaurants more
flexibility under the ppp that's what
we're talking about right
and protect workers and businesses alike
with curbs on
frivolous litigation frivolous
litigation a thing i know something
about
bristol litigation
going and sitting in your restaurant
tillman and then suing you for 10
million dollars because
something happened and they'll do it
anyway no matter what we give you
they're going to do it anyway you know
that
so uh i thank you all for being here
we'll take a couple of questions
john and if you have any questions for
these great restaurant tours please ask
well mr president first question for you
attorney general barr says he is
unlikely to have any criminal
investigation of either
barack obama or joe biden you've been
talking about what you call the greatest
political crime
uh in american history what do you think
of mr barrett's decision here well i
think it was me they would do it i think
for them maybe they're not going to i
don't know i'm surprised because
obama knew everything that was happening
i don't think obama knows
what was the crime against where he uh
you know is in a lot of ways i saw his
statements the other day and i think
that
frankly they weren't very good that's
president obama uh
as far as uh biden's concerned i can't
that i can't tell you
only he knows what he knows i don't
think he knows too much but i think
obama
and biden knew about it they were
participants
so i'm a little surprised by that
statement i don't think he said it quite
the way you said it i think he said as
of this moment i guess
but if it was me i guarantee they'd be
going after me uh
in his case uh they're not so i think
it's just a continuation of a double
standard i'm surprised by it
i'm surprised by it but uh
that's where it is and i don't know what
he said about this you have to
understand i was coming into this room
as that statement was being made so i
don't know exactly
he said we cannot allow this process the
legal process to be hijacked
by efforts to drum up criminal
allegations investigations of either
candidate
uh you seem to be suggesting well i
think you'd have to ask him what that
means
because i'm in no position to tell you
that i've stayed away from it
i'm relying on the attorney general to
do the job
and uh so i don't know exactly what he
said because i was
shot fired at bar disappointed if there
is no criminal investigation of biden
i don't see disappointed or not but i
have
no doubt that they were uh involved in
this
hoax one of the worst things ever to
befall
this country in terms of political
scandal any crime absolutely no doubt
that obama and biden were involved
and as to whether or not it was criminal
i would think
it would be very serious very very
serious
uh it was a uh
takedown of a president regardless of me
it happened to be me
and in my opinion it was an illegal
takedown
but i'm gonna let the attorney general
make all of those decisions i've stayed
out of it
because it's the appropriate thing to do
i wouldn't have to stay out of it as you
know but
i've decided to stay out of it so uh
i would say that i heard that just a
little while ago a few minutes ago i'll
have to look at it exactly as to what
was said what was
meant i will say this uh we have an
honorable attorney general
he's going to do an honorable job uncle
he's a very honorable man and he's going
to do a very honorable job but i am
surprised only in that i have no doubt
personally i have no doubt but he may
have another feeling i have no doubt
that they were involved in it
it's a hoax it started off with a
russian hoax no doubt
hoax involved not a list of crimes it's
just a whole
big disgrace and this country has better
things to do
it's a disgrace what they've done to
this country
with these phony investigations the
mueller
investigation was a waste of time from
day one they knew it was a waste of time
it proved to be a waste of time
i think there are a lot of bad people
involved and they should pay a very big
price if they were caught
so we'll see what happens but i rely on
the attorney general he's a very
honorable man
okay any other questions peter navarro
who said the cdc let the country down in
terms of testing
i think they work very hard don't forget
they've been here for many years it's
not
they don't work for me they work for the
country they've
they've worked very hard uh we
when we took over in terms of you know
getting involved mike headed up the task
force he worked with cdc
and i could ask mike to give you a part
you know part of it but
i will say they originally they had no
tests and
one of the tests had no test it's a new
virus
but that was quickly remedied and now we
have the best tests anywhere in the
world i think we i give ourselves a lot
of that credit
a lot of the brilliant people that
worked on testing a lot of the brilliant
people that worked on the ventilators to
a point where we have the best testing
in the world we have the best
ventilators and
distribution in the most ventilators in
the world it's not even close
uh so i can't do i would like to ask
mike that question
cdc you work with them all the time
certainly much more than i do mike
oh we do uh mr president and uh
all right guys pence and in fact this
went so much longer that i am at the end
of my time i've got to get to a uh to a
meeting but i appreciate everybody
joining me i i hear kaylee
maganny may be doing a press briefing
tomorrow if she does i'll be covering it
thanks for joining me
you